bonne nouvelle
[Musique]
présence de notre dame entre paris et le
ciel au dessus de la scène qui coule
comme nos jours au dessus des siècles
qui se défend présence envoûtante
présence qui pèse de tout son poids
d'éternité
notre dame pour vous monsieur
l'archiprêtre c'est bien plus qu'un
monument
on ne peut pas comprendre la cathédrale
si on ne tient pas compte de
l'aspiration qui a été à son origine la
cathédrale a surgi dans un siècle qui
était un siècle de foi et de recherche
extraordinaire assez semblable au siècle
nous sommes où la pensée chrétienne
rencontré une fermentation
intellectuelle d'exceptionnel et de tout
cela a pu jaillir ce monument
extraordinaire dont l'architecte
principal a été certes le maître
d'oeuvre dont on ignore le nom mais
l'architecte principal a été maurice de
sully qui était évêque qu'archevêque de
paris et qui avait passé le plus clair
de sa vie dans ce qu'on appelait le
cloître honneur aux dames une école
théologique l'école de la maîtrise aussi
dont vous aurez l'occasion de parler et
qui a été à l'origine de ce qui est
devenu le siècle suivant la sorbonne il
est impensable de vouloir comprendre la
cathédrale sont se replonger dans ce qui
a été l' enquête théologique et
spirituelle de ce 12ème siècle quand on
pense que saint thomas saint thomas
d'aquin est arrivé à paris en même temps
que son maître saint-albert de grands
legrand au moment où on finissait le
portail de notre dame
on comprend que c'est la même aspiration
qui a été à l'origine des sommes
théologique et de cette somme
théologique de pierre qu'à aider la
cathédrale avez vous vu
à l'intérieur de la cathédrale c'est ce
passage des piliers du bas et de sebah
côté où s'étale une sorte de pénombre
avec peu à peu une montée progressive
vers la lumière
en passant par un et filmant de ses
piliers massifs qui vont s'amenuiser peu
à peu qui vont se dédoubler pour devenir
tout au sommet comme on l'a dit et redit
mais combien cela est manifeste dans
notre dame de paris dont ce qu'on
pourrait appeler la voûte abstraite la
voûte intelligent cet intelligibilité
cette sorte d'abstraction lumineuse qui
nous est donnée dans la cathédrale
correspond exactement à lenquête
intellectuelle de cette époque deux fois
et deux raisons à là
monsieur bernard vitae et l'architecte
en chef des monuments historiques
et c'est à lui qu'il appartient de
s'occuper de notre dame c'est vous par
exemple qu'il y avait eu cette mission
de donner à notre dame saint couleurs
actuelles
oui sa couleur naturelle et c'était bien
intéressant mais bien en boisson car
notre dame étaient revêtus d'un enduit
noirâtre de suie de croûtes qui étaient
vraiment difficiles à enlever mais bien
aussi pour lapierre aussi est ce que
notre dame vous donne des inquiétudes
justement à cause de la qualité de cette
pierre aussi pour la qualité la qualité
est très bonne au sol air ambiant qui
est mauvais à qui doit-on penser quand
on pense à notre dame à qui doit-on
avoir de la reconnaissance pour cette
construction il n'y avait pas encore
d'architectes c'était les fameux
bâtisseurs de cathédrales c'était les
bâtisseurs de cathédrales mais dd
surtout mauriste subli qui a su voir qui
a su voir dans la basilique saint denis
qui est l événement est d'être inauguré
la 6ème de construction absolument
nouveau et tout ce mouvement des grandes
cathédrales de l'ile-de-france qui s'est
pas fait de retour de paris tout une
couronne de trois édifices que je ne
citerai pas ils sont reconnus mais et
qui dont les premiers ont servi de
prototype serveuse d'expérience comme ça
tu vis encore une fois soit son lit sans
fin les caméras le plus ancien de
l'autolog de paris pour la bâtir et on
voit sous toutes les parties rajouté par
exemple au 14e siècle le notre-dame
primitif avec ça a été commencé par le
cheveu par le coeur et on voit cette
architecture romane additionner
d'architecturé gothique et gothique
presque tardif et comme système de
construction ou c'est ce choeur n'avait
pas d' arc boutant on a inventé la rhk
bhoutan est tout de suite les
constructeurs a pris cette invention
merveilleux l on est servi pour
l'appliquer sur ses voûtes qui devait
tenir non pas qu'il est difficile de
tenir en équilibre
vous avez dit l'église c'est nous oui
l'église c'est nous parce que le temple
antique c'était à cela la boîte si vous
voulez qu'ils recevaient l'idole qui
recevait les prêtres et puis public et
aide au tour mais l'église l'église
chrétienne c'est le rassemblement de la
poule des chrétiens et il fallait que
l'église de la maison de dieu pour les
rassembler tous ensemble c'est pour ça
qu'il en fallait deux grandes de bell et
de portes
je vous demander ce que vous pensez de
viollet-le-duc j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration bon vieux c'est peut-être
des choses qui ne sont pas encore à dire
parce que trop de gens le déni mais
viollet-le-duc est un homme vraiment
extraordinaire et si vous considérez le
nombre d'architecturé le nombre de
l'église qu'on le dit réparé par
viollet-le-duc le nombre de dessins
extraordinaire ça il faut bien
l'admettre qu'il a fait c'est une
activité prodigieuse prodigieux et il
s'est trouvé à une époque où on avait
besoin de lui que comme viollet-le-duc
fait au point de vue archéologique des
erreurs c'est bien possible mais d'abord
ces deux langues le goût de son époque
et qui aurait t'il connu avant lui qui
lui a appris le contraire je crois que
vous avez encore en ce qui concerne
notre dame une ambition c'est le parvis
roger le monde je n'ai aucune ambition
sur le par picard moi personnellement je
ne m'occupe que de l'édifice mais
j'aurai l'ambition qu'on puisse voir ce
par midi libre que l'on puisse y
déambuler en quelque sorte il retrouver
l'aspect qu'il y avait à la création
d'autres fois d'un création de notre
dame
cette quasi liberté de la rue avec des
des petits marchands de tout est d'y
voir des d'écart déverser leurs
populations quelquefois curieuse c'est
tout à fait dans l'esprit de ceux des
pèlerinages d'autrefois est ce pas de
touche quant à notre dame
même dans l'église elle même ces gens y
retrouvent leurs fois regarder l'un
d'ailleurs il ne s'est pas n'importe qui
ce ne sont pas des touristes sont
vraiment souvent des chrétiens qui s'y
promènent
ici nous voyons très bien les tribunes
en fait l'emploi des tribunes étaient
très importants lorsqu'on a commencé la
construction de notre dame puisque en
163 ou connaissait pas encore l'emploi
de l'arc du temps alors nous allons
continuer maintenant par le soleil
alors vous voyez ici la clôture du coeur
qui a été fait par jean ravis et jean de
shell la nature ne sont pas les siennes
fait ce sont des personnes qui ont été
refaites par viollet-le-duc au 19e
siècle mais les sculptures date du 14ème
siècle
elle représente la vie du christ alors
que nous venons de voir de l'autre côté
les miracles du christ nous allons
continuer maintenant
oh
et
à toutes les grandes heures de notre
histoire on a entendu le bourdon de
notre dame et vous l'entendez
aujourd'hui alors que nous essayons en
sachant à quel point c'est parce qu'un
possible de faire un portrait est
télévisé de ce monument à l'acte de foi
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur l'archiprêtre le chanoine
bérard évoquait tout à l'heure la
maîtrise ce témoin de la vieille école
du poitou qui a plus de huit siècles
d'existence elle est située presque à
l'emplacement qu'elle occupait au
moyen-âge ce fut l'une des premières
écoles primaires de paris dont les
chanoines avait la charge dès le
douzième siècle des maîtres comme
léonard dans le grand enrichir les
thèmes grégoriens de toutes les
acquisitions rythmique des chants
profanes qui s'étendrait qu'aujourd'hui
on y enseigne la percussion
[Musique]
les grandes orgues de notre dame
il y avait déjà un orgue en lan et 1180
l'instrument actuelle garde encore
certains éléments de l'orgue construit
en 1733 par le facteur qui rit vous êtes
interne à deux pas de notre dame vous
allez souvent chanté à notre dame
quels sont ceux qui sont déjà montés en
haut des tours quels sont ceux qui
connaissent le trésor notre dame est
pouvez vous me citer des monuments qui
ressemble à notre dame
oui je peux vous en citer assez la
cathédrale de reims
un autre qu'elle cédera de chartres
[Musique]
sur les grandes orgues on a donné un
concert
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
le chanoine jean revers et maître de
chapelle à notre-dame et directeur de la
maîtrise dont il fut l'élève
il définit la vocation de la maîtrise eh
bien ces enfants sont en 1972
les héritiers ou les continuateurs de
ceux qui depuis plus de huit siècles ont
assuré au coeur de paris la plus belle
des missions de la musique celle de la
prière chanter
[Musique]
tous les événements qui ont compté
baisser notre pays ont été fêtés à notre
dame toute l'histoire de france se
répercute dans l'histoire de la
cathédrale et lloret possibilité depuis
ses débuts jusqu'aux temps les plus
proches d'écrire l'histoire de france à
partir de la cathédrale l'événement le
plus retentissant peut-être dans
l'histoire a été celui de cette messe
extraordinaire qui a regroupé le plus de
têtes couronnées du monde entier au
moment de la mort du général de gaulle
et où on a pu sentir l'emprise de la
cathédrale qui est éducatrice par
elle-même notre dame de la contemplation
pourrait-on dire qui saisit à qui sait
voir à qui sait se laisser prendre qui
saisit tout être humain qui entre dans
la bataille qu'ils soient croyants le
nom on est aspiré vers le haut
la cathédrale est faite pour l'homme
debout
l'homme qui doit normalement déboucher
dans la prière
et pour le chrétien qui entrent dans la
cathédrale aujourd'hui il est certain
qu'il se trouve dans un lieu privilégié
et c'est ce double aspect cet aspect
profondément humain d'une part qui est
fait de mesures qui est fait d'or qu'est
fait de spiritualité et d'autre part ses
aspects de fois qu'ils se retrouvent
pour ainsi dire tous les dimanches dans
ce que nous vivons à longueur d'année le
concert l'audition d'or comme nous
disons de trois quarts d'heure de tous
les dimanches que le devons à pierre
cauchon et à tous ses amis
atir 2500 à 3500 personnes dans un
recueillement extraordinaire dans les
postures qui rappelle celle de la rue
saint-andré-des-arts et celle de
katmandou où les nationalités diverses
se trouvent représentées comme autrefois
d'ailleurs au cloître de notre dame où
les étudiants étaient répartis en nation
et nous pourrions les répartir en nation
si on faisait un appel à la cathédrale
jusqu'à ses offices où manifestement le
moindre appel à la prière trouve une
résonance chez tous ces hommes et ces
femmes et ces jeunes et c'est plus âgées
qui viennent des quatre points cardinaux
et qui se sont donné rendez vous dans
notre dame de la mesure dans notre dame
de la contemplation dans notre dame de
france
[Musique]
ouvrier accumulé des siècles se poursuit
de jour en jour ainsi que l'écrit andré
malraux l'homme hors active et de la
pierre la seule humanité ou pu se
reconnaître le dieu qui la rachète à la
nuit la nef de la cathédrale sera devenu
le coeur du monde parce que la
cathédrale en sera devenu le miroir
[Musique]
à
hu
ah ah
[Musique]
et
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
wahaha
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]